[Music]
the ipad mini or the nexus 7. with the
holiday season right around the corner
these are the two tablets that are going
to be competing for your hard-earned
cash this is the battle of the mid-sized
tablets of
go ahead and hit that thumbs up button
and let's begin so this is a new product
category that was born in the second
half of 2012 with the nexus 7. these
devices are bigger than the largest
smartphones but smaller than your
traditional 10 inch tablet starting on
the outside in terms of pure hardware
right off the bat these are very
different tablets on the outside the
ipad mini takes the thinness crown and
it takes on a bigger footprint thanks to
that slightly larger display which we'll
talk more about in a second and the
nexus 7 on the other hand does feel a
little bit more natural to hold
especially with one hand and that's
partially thanks to that soft touch
material on the back and those rounded
edges that make it pretty comfortable
compared to the ipad's more premium
feeling industrial square style design
now besides the lightning port on the
ipad these tablets have a pretty similar
port and button situation going on
although the ipad's power button is up
top so that could get a little awkward
when trying to one-hand it but the ipad
mini does have the back camera advantage
so in the event you need to take photos
or video with your tablet the ipad's
your choice both do have a front-facing
camera though so that's convenient also
on the speakers the nexus 7 has an
average tablet bar speaker on the back
of the device it fires backwards but the
ipad mini has a much louder speaker but
the ipad mini speaker faces to the side
of the device meaning when you hold the
device in landscape mode it fires
sideways now for some reason the nexus 7
speaker didn't bother me but the
sideways audio from the ipad mini drove
me a little bit insane when trying to
game and watch youtube videos and
speaking of watching stuff the displays
are very important because that's what
you interact with that's what you're
constantly looking at when you're using
the tablets the nexus 7 has a pretty
average display it's not bad it's a
1280x720
seven-inch display which gives it a
pixel density of 216 ppi it's a pretty
decent display honestly it's not the
brightest in the world but it's
responsive and kind of crisp and it gets
the job done for the price you pay the
ipad mini on the other hand has a 7.9
inch display with a thinner smaller
bezel with a resolution of just
1024x768 this gives it a pixel density
of just
163 and i think this here is the ipad's
biggest flaw at least from my experience
apple really skimped on the display and
it is noticeable even when not directly
comparing it to a super high resolution
display side by side i noticed pixels
especially with text on the ipad mini
now that being said the next generation
ipad mini absolutely will have a retina
display of some sorts but until then
this is sort of the feature that does it
down for me i can see pixels everywhere
either way with this thinner bezel
sometimes you end up resting your finger
partially on the display so there's a
neat improvement made to ios
specifically for the ipad mini to reject
that accidental input so that's really
cool the nexus 7 has a thicker bezel
though so they i guess trust you in the
software not to accidentally touch the
screen but of course outside of the
hardware the other difference between
these two tablets is their operating
systems android 4.2 jelly bean on the
nexus and ios 6 on the ipad now besides
coming down to pure preference there are
some tangible differences like this
means you can pick between the google
play store and its 700 000 apps or the
apple app store and it's 1 million apps
one huge advantage for the ipad here is
at least because of this 1024 by 768
aspect ratio this is the same aspect
ratio as the ipad 2 and 3 and 4 so all
of the tablet optimized apps and games
that work perfectly on the ipads will
work on the mini just fine with no
letterboxing or stretching required so
it has the apps advantage here but then
again google maps or apple maps
google now or siri
youtube or no youtube it's your choice
i've also found that the battery life on
these two tablets is about the same
sometimes the ipad lasts a little bit
longer on standby when you're not using
it but once you really get to using
these two they're about even with each
other and for performance it's the
nexus's quad-core nvidia tegra 3 versus
the ipad's dual core a5 from the ipad 2.
and in real world performance both are
quite snappy no performance issues here
but i would say the ipad is overall
smoother but the nexus is overall faster
and i guess what i mean by that is the
frame rates and animations will be
faster on the ipad thanks to better
graphics but the load times will be
faster on the nexus 7 thanks to better
processing so in the end the wi-fi nexus
7 starts at 200 bucks while the
equivalent ipad mini is 330 bucks but i
gotta hand it to apple for giving it a
4g option which is nice while the
unlocked nexus will get you hspa plus
speeds overall you might go with the
ipad mini if you're familiar with or
enjoy and had simplicity of ios it's
like a large flattened out ipod touch
for 30 extra bucks think about that or
you might go with the nexus 7 if you
enjoy messing around with android or if
your budget is lower or if you do a lot
of video watching on a 16x9 display or
youtubing because of that youtube app
but you can't go wrong either way i'm
sure whichever you choose this holiday
season you won't be disappointed either
way thanks for watching if you enjoy the
video feel free to plus one or give it a
thumbs up here and enjoy your turkey day
if you celebrate it and i'll talk to you
guys in the next video peace
[Music]
you